back in Washington a stunning reversal
from former national security adviser
John Bolton he says he is willing to
give testimony at president Trump's
Senate impeachment trial if he is
subpoenaed Speaker Nancy Pelosi is still
withholding the articles of impeachment
from the Senate as the house returns
today Nancy Cordes is in Washington for
us Nancy good morning so big reversal
here how are lawmakers responding well
some Senate Republicans tell us that
they're interested in hearing what
Bolton has to say while others believe
that that's a decision that should be
made once the Senate trial actually gets
underway Bolton's testimony could be
intriguing because he was the
president's top foreign policy adviser
and we know from other witnesses that he
was troubled by the efforts to pressure
Ukraine into investigating Joe Biden one
former National Security Council
official for example fiona hill said
that at one point bolton likened the
efforts to a drug deal and told her and
others to alert White House lawyers
Democrats think he might know more about
the president's decision to withhold
millions of dollars in military aid to
Ukraine but Republican Senate Leader
Mitch McConnell says that all decisions
about witnesses should take place after
opening statements in the Senate trial
just like they did during the Clinton
impeachment trial more than 20 years ago
and the risk here is that if Senate
Republicans decide to hear from John
Bolton then it's going to be harder to
justify stopping there these Democrats
want to hear from a host of witnesses
that the White House blocked from
testifying before the House impeachment
inquiry this does sort of shake things
up Nancy thank you
you